stop the presses gang got a special
announcement the middle class famous
tour is in full effect hey your tickets
me the bald one the long hair we're
coming to a city near you bring the
squad out it's a great way to introduce
people to the show you get to see some
stand-up you get to play a little ayg
with me in the gipperino it's a good
time hit me out yeah guys we're going to
be in atlanta tampa orlando pittsburgh
buffalo detroit denver phoenix salt lake
city chicago rose man guys it's a great
time can't wait to see you out there get
your tickies now yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out the group to be classy yeah or
just a big old piece of trash don't say
i'm your host nate's fully coming at you
on a beautiful day down here at antony's
basement just realize i forgot the right
one my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he's the ceo of ru
garbage he is an international
businessman he's my best pal in the
whole world and i love him give it up
for kj
kevin bicky smalls james ryan
all right that now that was the first
funny tony i've ever heard uh guys
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are
cooking i forgot t-bone doesn't have a
mic this episode uh and then obviously
the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com
sign up you get bonus episodes bonus
live streams a whole nother podcast
check it out love that money and how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinary even though he
doesn't have a mic we love them to death
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin kobe
mcmullen
there you go round of applause he gives
up his mic because gang we have two
incredibly special guests here with us
today they've both been on the show
before we love them you love them they
have a brand new special out right now
called our special day they are the
hosts and the brains behind guys we
[ __ ] give it up for corinne fisher and
christina hutchinson everybody
scared us
in here i know
you're just like jackie kennedy i don't
know what the
i knew there was gonna be a comment
about this shirt
i feel like i should be giving you
cucumber sandwiches right now i would
love one
hutch keeps it real she's got holes in
her teeth
that's so funny because we were just
saying that we were talking about the
card store i was saying how cool it is
yeah that you're doing that meanwhile
hutch is uh sleep eating or whatever the
hell is going on
have you seen those videos uh i've seen
i've seen some instagram posts yeah tell
me that's
you're doing that without knowing it i
do it without knowing i get up in the
middle of the night as if i smelled
smoke
and i dart to the kitchen i don't
remember until the next day because the
next day i'll wake up and i'll
if you look at my counter it looks
normal and then as you approach you see
spoons in the sink that have peanut
butter on them that i've been licking
and then often times you'll see a peanut
butter jar still open in the sink it's
like a real throwdown she's eating all
different kinds of [ __ ] probably like
beef jerky on the couch the only thing
that saves you it's all classy stuff it
looks like all trader joe's stuff
but still dude that's crazy anything in
the sleep is garbage i like that trader
joe's is classy to you because when you
said that i was like ill
he's more of a key foods kind of guy
i like my sushi a week older aldo
oh all the old aldi all these
shoes you got to bring the uh the cart
back for a quarter
but guys congratulations on the special
this is absolutely [ __ ] fantastic
thank you vale
valentine's day it came out yep and what
is the significance of valentine's day
what's the story here just relationship
you know really brand relationship
podcast relationship dad we didn't put
much you know it was supposed to come
out on christmas honestly and paul would
ruin that so we're like all right which
reminds me yeah
you got coleman that was very buyer
i know i don't know why i said it like
that we got you two valentine's day
conversations thank you and i got them
in a wawa wow
i love conversation hearts
they're they're literally awesome i love
valentine's day sweet tarts has taken
them over i think what right aren't they
sweethearts
well they mean these are different
they're different these are the ones no
those are the eco ones those are the
originals exactly i thought i got the
chalky the chalky ones those are the
best the one with the nico wafers they
were [ __ ] yeah i like those
these are nice thank you this is very
nice do you guys like valentine's day
wow
[Laughter]
i wish they were the sweet tarts on when
i think of valentine's day i go back to
being a little kid and who got the
valentine's this is gonna get sound this
could be good this could be very good or
very bad i'm so stressed he started
therapy recently so you're in for a
bumpy ride oh i'm so happy for you
wait how many sessions did you go to i
went to two and i switched over to
sprite things are going pretty good i
don't want to talk about it
no only i went i went since october i
feel like i got a really good handle on
uh since october i'm telling you i think
i got a really good handle on my
situation my situation
i got a really good handle it's a toxic
statement that's how all the time holy
[ __ ] oh
i'm not relaxing you gotta hit him girl
[Laughter]
this is [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right now i've been working out with
a trainer since december yeah okay
and and you didn't quit no i'm not
quitting that okay and i'm not going
that because obviously i know i still
have a long way to go with that but with
the therapy i realized through through
therapy through work they're working
really hard on it for a few months is
that a lot of the stuff i was just
overthinking is and is in my head in a
way and they're not like real real
situations and she taught me how to
address those things are you having
hallucinations what do you mean they're
not real situations you know like
[Laughter]
my mom just dropped a raisin bran
watching this what the [ __ ] man i got to
see these people in real life
i've been going bowling for the last two
weeks every day that's kind of like
therapy okay yeah all right that's very
jersey no i i feel like i feel like i
did it to where i needed it and
that is insane why was that insane you
only went a couple months you've lived a
whole lifetime it wasn't a couple month
october november december january i went
four more that's a couple of years
that's a cup two's a couple of now we're
doing this what am i what are we on
crazy bills
we all know that okay toby say something
you see him you go to commercial you see
me
see how flustered he's got
where's those goddamn helix mattresses
your relationship with attachments has
gone nowhere though like you're
you're getting stuck on [ __ ] i just
think you gotta go back to therapy you
that's a rookie four months four months
you're not even cracking the surface is
it impossible to be honest are you
scared of what you're gonna find out no
i'm honestly not scared i figured it all
out i don't know if you picked that up
but you it's all done i think i said
that he did my life too they moved quick
this guy i'm all healed the therapist
retired
my whole family you two cleaned up my
whole family's completely normal now i'm
telling you i've never witnessed anybody
so speedy with therapy i mean i think
there's a lot of people that go for a
little while and yeah yeah they're
called crazy yeah
they're called i don't wanna know what's
in the box why are you staring at me
like that wait okay so did you go on
your own free will or did your fiance
make you go that wasn't court appointed
well a lot of times it's it was bad
court it was
appointed i they started to put the
screws to me a little bit we do fat
court on the patreon uh
we got them well we got them you know
we're trying to get them to lose weight
now now that this thing's cooking i need
a paycheck yeah
okay right right i can't have him those
kia payments don't pay themselves
got it um so i got them we got them with
a trainer we got them on like you know a
diet
somewhat you know uh but i wanted it as
a therapist good good i found the
therapist myself i stuck it out and
found it and stuff like that i was
motivated to go and i'm telling you i
went in there with everything now now
let me ask you this i told her
everything how did you tell her hey
that's a wrap
uh this is just a couple days ago but
like how did you do it yeah what did you
say to her when was her how did you
break up with your therapist you dumb
[ __ ]
you never loved me listen i think we
should see other people anything he said
um no i just said hey uh you know
with my schedule and stuff like that oh
god
i can't win over here
no matter what i say i'm gonna be wrong
i'm telling you guys that's how you go
back to therapy i feel good i i'm i'm
using the tools that i've that that
taught me there and applying it to my
life and moving forward with the working
out and stuff like that right because
that has even started to make me feel
better well a physical fitness goal
that's what i'm mental yeah a physical
fitness goal is really monumental
because it is it is a direct metaphor
for like progress for bettering yourself
of course results unfold so when i say
to you guys that a lot a lot of the
stuff was in my head all right a lot of
it was like things that that i you know
i was i was feeling sorry for myself and
making it worse and it was and i don't
really have as many problems as i
thought i did i just needed to start
moving forward and stop being lazy i i
appreciate that feedback though because
that should be isolated and sent out to
a lot of people on yeah mostly men yeah
so there you go a lot of women too
honestly just a lot of people in general
there you go so that's why yeah okay i
didn't know i was gonna be called out in
on the show what face did your therapist
make when you uh told her that you were
quitting did she like she didn't send me
an emoji bag what are you talking about
oh so you text messages
you know what you would have heard you
would have heard her go
oh my god okay
i'm sure she has your opinions on it all
right which are completely valid and i
understand
i like how i'm not the bad guy anymore i
can i can throw my feet up on this one
i'm typically the guy screaming at him
this is great i wanted to talk about
valentine's day
okay we can talk about valentine's
[Laughter]
i said if you know if i feel the need
that i that i need to go back you know
i'll be the first one to reach out which
i will yeah yeah which i will if your
schedule clears up yeah yeah
i believe angel clears up i mean he's
got to be he works two days a week
that's a lot okay
what do you mean we're always moving
around doing stuff like walk into the
subway and going to the elevator
[Music]
[Laughter]
so so valentine's day yeah so yeah back
to my childhood
the only kid without a lollipop
did that really happen no of course not
what do you mean he was probably a real
go-getter it was like don rickles back
then or track suit and stuff like that
well you seem sad about it so i just
didn't know i didn't mean for it to
sound sad but when i think about it
that's what i go back to that's where
like because like uh i'm very nostalgia
attached yeah i mean for lack of a
better word so that's what i think of
attached to the past that
[Laughter]
not anymore i'm standing outside of her
office with the boombox over my head i
want you back baby
i love that
oh my god no but the fun of it you know
without relationships yeah when it was
innocent when it was simple when you
gave this
now in the back of your head yeah you
did feel like a bozo if so-and-so didn't
you didn't get that valentine right but
it was more fun the night before putting
all the candy together writing out the
cards anybody in your family pronounce
it valentine oh yeah it's the trashiest
thing valentine's day
boy that's bad i don't uh are you doing
anything this year for valentine's day
yeah spots
oh
what you're not going out with your
beloved i i my anniversary was two days
ago so we do it was the seventh so did
you purposely have it by valentine's day
so you guys with two for one yeah
we go out and do stuff all the time yeah
well
yeah you live together but like
yeah it's called a relationship
we're always stepping up together be on
your toes be a little bit more romantic
dress up a little bit of course of
course and we've been doing that a lot
more to be honest with you uh which is
really nice but yeah i'm sure i'm sure
we'll celebrate it not you know not that
night but like you know the next day a
cheaper night yeah what is that they're
gonna start charging more on valentine's
day yes they do this is who you are
yeah
you go to gallagher's tonight you get a
steak for the same price you get enough
they don't jack up the prices take your
wife or your girlfriend to the place
that me you and toby go and get you i
didn't i just used as man i'm really
getting it from all angles
i can't buy a break
i'm using as an as an example i never
know but things are inflated on
yeah
one meal they do a pre-fix valentine's
day just so you buy hallmark cards like
it's all money anyway but you know we we
disguise it as like let's celebrate love
which i'm happy with according to
gilmore girls there actually is a real
historical like more meaningful uh
background to valentine's day but i
didn't look it up after i watched that
episode i thought it was about the mob
boston probably involved what saint
valentine's day massacre i thought that
it was named after uh well no i think
the massacre came after the day yeah
there's a massacre yeah yeah same
valentine's day massacre yeah big mob
paint up in the north oh [ __ ] yeah no
chocolate net
nope no sweethearts on those streets
would you get upset if your uh
significant other was like we're gonna
go out the 13th or the 15th if there
there better be a real yeah it's better
because i'm busy oh yeah but it's yeah
it's because we're busy yeah yeah
nothing of a show which we usually do
honestly so it's a big night you know it
is a comedy comedy yeah yeah do we do
you guys know what you're doing for that
night yeah i mean we're promoting our
special there you go
so you're working so you're gonna go out
on another time but there's a two-hour
window before in which dylan better
[ __ ] take me somewhere
and i'm gonna be alone masturbating so
get ready i'm listening
[Laughter]
what are you doing kev i just said uh i
mean i'm working oh you're working i'm
working but typically oh yeah and you're
not celebrating because you just have
your interview
why aren't you yelling at him the way
you were yelling at me
i don't know he got married so yeah
wow [ __ ]
wait you are engaged though right no i'm
not engaged oh i said
i guess just because
just because it's been so long you know
so
you still came in with it oh man they
did i like it
we don't [ __ ] around right here come
bearing gifts
thought you were gonna [ __ ] say
you're gonna make it all easy peasy with
candy hearts i will say foley has given
me more like has given me more things
and like little thoughtful gestures than
most of boyfriends i've had like one
time i was at new york comedy club
sweetheart and i just mentioned i wanted
a diet coke and he like went and brought
me a diet coke and that was very very
nice of you now granted i was going to
pick up my sandwich
i was meeting my drug dealer on the
corner yeah but you didn't have to go
and get it tripp's
yeah you still got it
that was very nice that's a good thing
he's gonna be here in five minutes i'll
grab you one
uh yeah so i'm not doing any and i don't
think last year was our one year we
didn't do it because we went out we went
away for our
uh anniversary so it's like yeah you
know yeah it's just like he just did a
day spa you guys just did a day spot
yeah that's nice yeah yeah yeah
did you enjoy it yes i enjoy you know uh
self-care you know okay uh hitting the
the steam rooms the saunas yeah
the pools it's over there in jersey i
would check it out so joe it's called oh
no it's like a bath house guys it's huge
yeah i thought i was gonna make this
little piece of [ __ ] it's enormous wow
like eight floors i think my gay friends
went there yeah yeah it's like you can
see the city there's like an infinity
pool wow
you walk in they take your shoes
immediately really yeah you like hand
them your credit card and a guy undoing
your shoes
[Laughter]
oh
[Laughter]
how do you guys feel sorry how do you
feel about the infinity pool you brought
it up is that is that an end goal oh
beautiful yeah i mean that plays an
infinity pool yeah yeah
i'm always scared i'm going to break it
like i'm going to fall in love with it
it's where the water goes over it yeah
okay so how do you break it cause isn't
it like usually like a thin wall on that
side i think it looks thin but it's
actually quite concrete it's just like
the pool then really just ends i'm
talking about the ones that have the
glass where you can see people swimming
in them oh i wouldn't trust you in one
of those no no no no no no that's what
i'm talking about the poor people on the
outside of that class god damn just
magnify you i fled the san fernando
valley
put on a forest fire though so it all
worked out
oh my god kip athletic greens athletic
greens no i'm not i'm the athlete and a
bunch i know all about athletic greens
i'm not just uh they're not just a
sponsor i'm also a client yeah use it
every day use it at the gym put the
water shake it up
drink it throughout my workout feel
great feels smooth the taste is
fantastic i love me athletic greens he's
a big ag-1 guy that's right guys it's
like a super multi-vitamin it's got
everything you need all in one stop
shopping gut health immunity costs less
costs less than three dollars a day if
you're investing in your health it's
cheaper than your cold brew habit
uh if you're investing in all-in-one
nutritional insurance look at it that
way you're taking you're checking
everything all the boxes there you go
with ag-one uh cheaper than getting all
different supplements yourself uh
athletic greens has over seven thousand
five-star reviews recommended by
professional athletes trusted by leading
health health
health experts kippy can't talk today
right now
it's time to reclaim your health and arm
your immune system with a convenient
daily nutrition especially heading in to
flu and cold season just one scoop of
water uh just one scoop and a cup of
water every day that's it no need for a
million different pills supplements to
look out for your health uh take it easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com garbage again that's
athleticgreens.com garbage to take
ownership of your health and pick up the
ultimate daily nutritional insurance
kip let's talk about bombas bombers you
know them you love them gang bomba's
mission is simple
very simple yeah make the most
comfortable clothing ever and match
every item sold with an equal item
donated so when you buy bumbus you're
also giving to someone in need the
clothes are absolutely comfortable
they're absolutely fantastic and they're
doing a great thing most number one
requested thing that people ask for at
homeless shelters is socks yes and
they're giving them away everything they
make a soft seamless tagless has a
luxurious feel and as a piece of trash i
am it's nice to have something feel a
little luxurious yes sir you know what i
mean uh there's a pair of bomber socks
for everything you do they come in tons
of options like comfy performance styles
for every sport or activity that keeps
you moving the t-shirts are made of
thoughtful designs features invisible
seams soft fabrics
and the perfect weight so they hang just
right you know what i mean so go to
bombas.com garbage get 20 off your first
purchase that's b o m b a s dot com
garbage for 20 off your first
purchase bomas.com garbage do it do it
all right let's get into some cues yeah
guys so uh as you know when you join the
patreon we will answer answer your
garbage question on the air um so let's
see here um
this is from uh no kante for old yams oh
that's pretty good because jack conte
and sam yam are the owners of uh patreon
who we say a prayer to every day
i think we should say one hour
um
do you drive your car barefoot
yep no that's illegal
it
is and new jersey's yeah my mustang i
can see how to doing that in the winter
yeah 100 i also forgot how to drive
though full disclosure you don't drive
anymore i forgot i moved to new mexico
i moved to manhattan when i was 17. and
i just never was here anymore oh yeah
i'll give you that so yeah you what do
you do when you gotta get back and forth
to the store uh oh i take i take ubers
everywhere damn
that ain't in the city toby i'll tell
you that no yeah
yeah
going out of the city in the car that's
close he's out oh or a little dial seven
you know car service yeah really carmel
one time i took a new service better
than carmel but yeah my brother's in
pennsylvania really yeah
that's pretty good they're nice they're
actually you know what they're nicer to
my dogs
you're not talking about carrie
limousine are you no not carrie
limousine no there's like there's like
caramel and then a step up from carmel
is dial seven and the re i use like i
dial seven is nicer to animals that's
why i i choose them are they always old
lincoln town cars um it can be like it's
suvs a lot
that's nice i like that
cars
so i love like an suv because i just get
i do a lot of sleeping on transportation
man's hugging you yeah
hutch is driving with her knee yeah i
feel hutch's hunch like a couple weeks
away from seeing her to drag race and
she'll be down there revving her engine
well now i we had a listener uh talk to
me about drifting they like drift like
all the time it's like their hobby uh
because i was in my mustang i didn't
realize mustangs are death traps in the
snow i saw this storyline yeah
i almost died twice i almost ran right
into a semi-truck like it was i've never
felt unsafe in a car in my life i love
cars i love driving that [ __ ] scared
the [ __ ] out of me you have to to winter
as a mustang you have to get separate
tires which makes sense but you also
have to put 300 pounds in the trunk
cause it's a two-door coupe yeah it's a
rear-wheel drive yeah so you're all over
so it's too powerful of a vehicle like
you i was oh my god did you do all that
stuff
no i didn't i didn't have anything to
wait it down i was on the highway's know
but i could give him a loose can i get a
ride let me look at my schedule but i
think i'm free tuesday
you can put it but where you usually did
therapy you can get in here
it's almost the same thing listen
um no have you done that stuff since
then did you get the new tire no i'm
just i'm not taking that car when it's
snowing i'm not gonna be driving it yeah
all right you also have to be a very
skilled driver which is why i was
thinking about drifting because that's
the way you maneuver the car like when
you fish tail in rear wheel drive you
gotta go with the car you got to steer
with the car when you fish tail in
all-wheel drive you go against the car
but this isn't your four in the drifting
now you're talking to people out
drifting no we're not going to catch
over on the the northeast extension in
the middle of the night no well my
brother drifts my brother we're car
people so like he was trying to teach me
he goes still
100 oh my we have a 76 trans am we got a
68 camaro yeah yeah uh but he said like
a skilled driver could technically get
home in your mustang in the blizzard i'm
like wow
really yeah if you're [ __ ] cool or
something like that yeah you have to
really be like a [ __ ] nascar
[ __ ] i just drove oh sorry you
were about what what is drifting
queen elizabeth joined us ladies and
gentlemen i literally don't know what
you're talking about
more champagne to me drifting drifting
is like when a guy starts to get cold to
you and then answers your text messages
it's what she thinks
i've heard of tokyo drift like
yeah are you supposed to do that uh yeah
you can you can you gotta do it
it's like a sport it's like giant drag
racing okay okay okay it's a very
similar drag racing in terms of they do
this in greece guys
i'll be honest i'm surprised your car
doesn't have more aftermarket effects
to be quite honest yeah i'm surprised
there's names on it and [ __ ] i said i
figured you'd have like i got two racing
stripes
yeah that's of course
that's really bad yeah but that clears
that killed them that came with parkour
gray yeah charcoal yeah
yeah well it's charcoal gray with white
racing straps oh i didn't even notice
the racing yeah they're they're ombred
almost so it's like yeah you guys car is
beautiful it's a girl term and a boy
together you guys left casey and
robbie's wedding like night rider you
[ __ ] like you blew by the after party
doing like 80. talking the horn and
i love it christine is like my boyfriend
driving me around yeah oh i'll get us
when we got a gig in like baltimore
after the saturday night show i'm like
let's do this we're going to go home
when the headlines off no one will see
you
cops won't stop you
about four of the six hours we were in a
snowstorm
not good we rented an suv okay okay
because i have a camera i was gonna say
motorcycle to sound
it was and i played a pretty good like
i'm confident i'm like i got this yeah
but there was moments where i was just
like i was guys do you want me to pull
over yeah like because yeah well i mean
yeah there was like tractor trailers
flying past yes i voted yes and was
outvoted by everybody
i hate that [ __ ] i don't like driving in
the rain like that
we went to get our christmas tree and it
was pouring rain and we drove up [ __ ]
somewhere up there
coming home dicey irrational fear
there's someone you could talk to about
that yeah yeah it's not an irrational
thing you could hire a professional
somebody
it's not an irrational fear it's a
rational fear
spiders you're afraid of the rain that's
a pretty irrational friends are driving
their rights enya yeah
so zenyatta what is she
about that i feel like she does
i was like the wicked
that was great
i didn't get it
to be honest we're being honest here um
all right this is from this is from
bernie sanders uh
when you're moving out of an apartment
have you ever taken all the light bulbs
with you
which is i never thought about but a
dirt bag that is a dirt bike if you're
undoing like the ceiling like this come
on yeah yeah yeah i know i'll take the
blinds with i did just move forward i
was in a place for 11 years i left the
blind i left shelves i actually left
furniture they actually charged me for
it um but i left a lot of [ __ ] yeah of
course always i'll figure it out when i
get there ice and all that old stuff
feels so good when you're getting a new
spot it's yeah you're nude yeah i've
i've never thought about taking the
light bulbs but like it is not a bad
idea now that i think about it
what if it's like one of those really
long like the ones they're supposed to
last for like 10 years the eco-friendly
ones i would i would unscrew one of
those okay
yeah topic a 13 year old boy the
apartment's all blacklight
[Laughter]
now i see corrine's point if you just
put them in and there are those nice new
expensive ones but there's something
about the idea of after you move out
your landlord coming in to show the new
tenant and he flicks the light and it's
[ __ ] completely dark you're a [ __ ]
scumbag it's very how the grinch stole
christmas
no light for you yeah
or if you just went through like some
breakup or something like that then i
can get on board with that i specialize
you gonna do some petty moves oh i love
doing putty moves the petty moves i'm
always on board for yes
super glue the keyholes
you're just giving me ideas now that's
great
yeah that's you can't do that that'll
[ __ ] a place up no you gotta knock the
door down of course yeah who cares yeah
not your problem
all right hey whatever jesus christ
um all right this one's from our boy
alex tonello up in boston is it garbage
to lie about your anniversary on
vacation to get free champagne and
chocolates that's a given do that yeah
i have never done it but
fanfare but most restaurants have caught
on like for birthday or whatever they
charge you for the cake or whatever that
they give you because too many people
were doing that that's how like accepted
garbage that is wow wow
you can't you can't have a country of
garbage one of life's purest joys is
having a fake birthday party on a night
that's not your birthday party and
getting a free piece of cake and getting
like a whole thing wait i want to sing
to you that's insane but they don't
that's not the shirt talking i can tell
you that
that shirt's definitely rented by the
way no i yes yes it is 100 percent i've
never heard a [ __ ] you're like [ __ ]
tmz today you're blowing up everybody i
don't mind i tell everyone i don't i've
never done it
kimmy's getting real gossipy i like it
i've never done it because i don't like
attention and except for when i decide i
like attention um but yeah they for many
many years they charge you for that cake
so it's just like so many people were
doing it you so you can't do it anymore
yeah will you do it on your birthday or
no even if it is your birthday no i
would i oh my god i hate when people do
[ __ ] like that i have i have fringe
worthy to me it's just wait so you won't
do the fake birthday or you will
i i my i think my point is like i will i
would never shame anyone for doing that
it's so it's fun but i personally
wouldn't want it done to me because i
don't want the whole restaurant singing
to me that's like ugh yeah that's the
worst thing in the whole restaurant
i yearn for love 24 7. yeah yeah
everybody everybody's singing to me it's
my birthday right now guys well my
birthday is next saturday february 19th
it is soon don't you ever forget the
world thank you happy birthday thanks i
don't know i think that's i think the
more dignified they're not even
dignified but the cooler move as you get
older you
i guess when you're checking when you're
checking in that's all right i think
you're like oh are you celebrating
anything you're like oh it's our
anniversary and they pour champagne free
at like the front desk while you're
getting your room or whatever that's all
right i'm okay with that they mean i
would never do it because i'm gonna you
know distinguish gentlemen right but i
get it they made me having fun they made
me a swan out of towels in costa rica
because i wrote like in the thing that
it was my birthday and i appreciated
that
yeah that was you know another country
yeah
you can't be lying to detroit you know
what i mean until you until you start
getting desperate then you're going into
places like i got three weeks to live
what can you do for me what's the mini
bar situation that's really funny make
sure the oj's fresh squeezed
good question uh love you alex yes um
alex this is from matthew first time
long time the acronyms ftlt which is
first time a long time then they do
uh f-y-o-a
f-y-o-a-y-k
have you or anyone you know had an
inflatable hot tub
yeah yeah no someone i know in brooklyn
has one
in brooklyn yeah i thought it was a
great idea for the city that's all right
the city i'll give you yeah yours is
virginia in virginia
yikes
where i would attend nascar races at the
richmond tracks the shortest track in
all of nascar three quarters of a month
they're doing a short track down there
they got the sprinters out yeah yeah
they do it
five hours before you get that trick
i have a blow up kiddie pool in my
backyard though in manhattan
that i is that mostly for the dog though
no it's not for me it's hard it's heart
shaped
it's hard oh that's fine
my dog doesn't like water do you have a
hose to fill it up uh there's no water
source in the back so i gotta do a
bucket or like oh my god
actually you know what cut it print it
that's a wrap like you're putting at a
barn fire what the [ __ ] just like seven
people passing a bucket back and forth
hurry up to mills burning
what are you doing
it's a wooden bucket too i did something
even worse actually because it was the
bucket thing was so hard
no i tried to let
rain water fill it up and then i bought
chlorine tabs off of amazon and i was
like i'll just chlorine clean the rain
water
you're making a chemical bomb what are
you talking about
the neighbors think you're making meth
in the backyard
did you get into that did you say that
it just didn't really work out and then
and it's this summer but next probably
dried you out your skin terribly no it's
all right i don't know what drying out
your skin i mean i just you had to skim
some mosquitoes out of it but
[Laughter]
a couple of dead rats really i don't
care about stuff like that yeah yeah
you gotta be comfortable with vermin
when you've lived in manhattan for i've
lived here for 18 years
yeah i don't call them vermin either
that's a little strange why that's what
just comfortable with them i don't know
there was a rat that was coming through
my stove and i didn't want to kill them
so i trapped them and i trapped them in
a little um harmfree trap and i brought
them to a garden
that's adorable what he's too sweet i
don't i don't like killing animals i
found a baby wrapped in my own i know
but listen i don't like killing animals
it was sweet but i don't mind it there
was no need there was a simple solution
to it but a rat they could bite you they
could get at you no no they're angry no
no no he he caught yourself in the in
the
tree trap
so he wasn't gonna bite me he just got
lit some peanut butter it was closed and
then i let it out it's easy you don't
have to touch them or go near them at
all
yeah that's the point of the cruelty
free trap i got you
i got you
my wife tried to get us to do that i
still probably took somebody's dad away
or mom away you didn't think about that
well i mean according to rat tattooey
they're all on the wall well there was
like three that i caught so i let them
all out into the same garden
yeah this is the place you're in now
yeah
yeah well first floor man rats yeah
mice is one thing fish rats are
intelligent
yeah i live on the first floor and i
have an outdoor space there's a
successful rat problem and i live
downtown yeah everyone had rats i had
rats when i lived in the first floor
yeah
it's worth it honestly i love it i feel
like these two girls were put together
no i love the east village so much it's
worth the rats you know special
successful podcasts development deals
you're killing it
[Laughter]
you can't there's no humane way you take
it to a park it's just they're just
gonna infest the park yeah they're
already in the park there's some kids
getting bent on a juggle gym
last time i'm a [ __ ] rat i know a guy
bit by a guy yeah who probably
was poking it or doing something to
deserve it yeah he's doing something he
shouldn't have been doing baby i don't
like those squirrels i want to go on
record i don't like those oh they're
adorable you're crazy no way i fed a
raccoon with my hand in costa rica too
oh costa rica yeah that's all right
yeah remember the raccoons broke into my
into me and dylan's suite and then we
started and it ate all of my it ate all
of my expensive mini bar food but then
we invited it back basically by leaving
a trail and then we started feeding it
cookies with our hand it was my favorite
part of the costa rican then the
raccoons got diabetes
i [ __ ] love animals
any chance against a raccoon broke into
your room yeah and ate my mini bar food
and then you started feeding it yeah
because you have hands man raccoons have
[ __ ] hate they can shoot guns you're
crazy and rats rats have hands like that
rats are grippy hands
i don't like any of that thick tail i
just love them they got that tails like
an extension tail is wild tail scared
yeah rats are just scary
and that's crazy with the raccoon you're
nuts hmm
jesus it was so sweet it was a mommy
raccoon and then there's three babies
that takes you down in the classy points
you know that right they went swimming
in my in we had okay so the room had
rats in your oven what the [ __ ] we had
we had a private a private pool for the
room but then
i let raccoons go swimming in it
[Laughter]
i picked myself like pocahontas like
just talking to the creatures and like
you know chatting with them it's fun
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy relationships take work
everybody knows that you know what a lot
of us will drop anything at the drop of
a hat to help somebody that they care
about out but will you do that for
yourself probably not no probably not
this month better helps want everybody
to know that the most important
relationship you have is with yourself
okay whether it's hitting the gym
whether it's making time for a haircut
doing something for you and going to
therapy is a great thing i just left my
therapist and i'm signing her for better
help better get to do it right in the
comfort of your own home do it baby love
it better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see someone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours give it a try and see why
over 2 million people have used better
health therapy online this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp and ayg
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com garbage that's better
help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p dot-com
garbage do it yeah let's talk about
ladder ladder life is fragile as we know
you ain't lying you don't want to leave
nothing to your family if god forbid the
words happens and ladder can help yeah
everybody gets scared off at term life
insurance the latter makes it quick they
make it easy no doctors visits no
nothing
fantastic 100 ladders 100 digital like
you said no doctors no needles no
paperwork when you apply for 3 million
in coverage or less you just need a few
minutes a phone a laptop to apply ladder
smart algorithms working in real time so
you'll find out if you're instantly
approved and you choose there you go uh
if you prefer to talk to a person the
team of licensed agents doesn't work on
commission so the they'll help you not
upsell you there you go you know what i
mean that's the way to do it no hidden
fees cancel at any time get a full
refund if you change your mind in the
first 30 days latter policies are issued
by insurers with long proven histories
of paying claims they're rated a and a
plus by am's best not bad stick that in
your pipe and bite down look at that i
mean so go to ladderlife.com garbage
today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com garbage
ladderlife.com garbage now back to the
show back to the show
i did that that's how i spent my
quarantine hanging out with pigeons what
yeah we'll go down the river
oh like we like animals and birds pigeon
oh i don't like i hate
birds pigeons are just doves these two
seem perfectly normal pigeons are rats
with wings i don't know what happened no
pigeons are really intelligent and
they're ancient forms of communication
with carrier pigeons and stuff they're
incredibly intelligent creatures
christina loves him alone too yeah so
yeah okay now we're getting now we're
getting somewhere i also found a 12 year
old magician in australia that was
teaching you how to get a dove to land
on you and i'm like well doves are
doves or pigeons with gray feathers so i
can do that with that's not no but it
works but you're trying to train a city
pigeon to land on your shoulder yeah i
have videos of it
toby's face
i wore gloves
i was the founder
yeah listen we're animal lovers too we
love animals too but this is
crazy behavior it's just screwballs
we've brought this podcast to screeching
wow yeah i might have to go back to this
everybody tell her about this he
rendered them speechless that is
impressive i mean i knew you were trashy
but like you do come off of the with
class well that's that's a big mistake
they're both very classy in a lot of
regards
i got a lot of sides i'm an octopus
knock off the steve irwin stuff
city with city beth yeah
that's vermin
the pigeons would be considered vermin
too i believe
but not the squirrels pigeons are
originally cliff birds like they would
hang out on cliffs and they were brought
over to america so they they kind of do
where'd they come from where do pigeons
come from um i wha why don't i say
africa i want to say uh they originated
they're they're but they were in
somewhere where there was a lot of
cliffs because i remember i remember
reading about that when i was learning
how to get them to land on me and um
it made a lot of sense that they are
like dwell on these built on the
building building buildings yeah yeah i
don't know
do you ever then do you never see a cute
one they're always banged up
like missing like a claw or they've got
warts on them some of them are a little
like you know crosstalk city it's not
great yeah at heart they're cute
circumstances have dictated now they
carry a lot of disease but yeah there
you go
i know you do that too exactly
you know you mean the coroner's got more
stds than he'll ever know so it's like
you know who's more dangerous had you
guys have pet birds growing up at all
yeah yeah my brother had one that he
accidentally killed because before we
left for a vacation he had the food and
he but he forgot to open the cage and
put the food in the cage so we left the
food right outside the cage and we came
home and the bird was dead
yeah
he was terri he was so upset damn yeah
like the bar is a little bent yeah
he's trying to get his head in the food
was right in front of the cage he forgot
to put it in i'm like oh dude that sucks
damn maybe not the best person to be
keeping pigeons i'll say that
that was my brother rob's in the family
and then you had one we had a finch
named rebo yes did he talk
[Laughter]
you guys should get a parrot that's like
a toucan or something like that
there's no [ __ ]
did he talk i don't [ __ ] know kind of
tricksy though
listen i don't like birds at all
at all um all right this one's from
luigi f baby
do you ever choose the high c as your
fountain drink at a fast food restaurant
never i've done it at the high sea
orange at mcdonald's because everything
yeah yeah yeah actually recently when uh
because i was on keto for our special
and then i went like balls to the wall
that i i hadn't eaten meat in like years
i went crazy i was eating funyuns and
doritos and twizzlers like i i went i
went wild you're trashy with your food
taste yeah my palette is yeah what is it
what is a balls to the wall order at
mcdonald's for corinne fisher uh good
question well i mean
i don't i don't eat meat anymore but for
this one night i did so i had my mind
you're talking to a convicted felon over
here
okay
you do like ideally if you're eating all
the things you eat a two cheeseburger
meal large obviously and then uh like a
chicken sandwich and an
order of nuggets and oh and this is like
okay so this is almost this is trashy
but wait the two burgers and a chicken
sandwich i would normally i would do
one like non-chicken nuggets and then
one chicken nuggets i've got enough i've
gotten i've split a 40 piece nugget with
a friend like that's easy yeah that's no
problem respectable and then fillet of
fish which is probably the trashiest
item on the menu is arguably the best
item
people don't eat it enough but it's like
so good and that's what i eat now
because that i stopped eating um i only
eat fish now so okay it's so good it was
andy warhol's favorite sandwich
yes
he's the one who convinced me to eat it
reading a book about it
i thought he called you one day not even
joking i was like if it's good enough
for andy warhol it's good enough for me
but that and the pigeon facts is just
yeah you didn't know what you were gonna
get today but boy oh boy
you hit us with that at the end of a
statement and it's always so
authoritative
authoritative they hit us with like a
fact
i love party facts
you don't like facts
well not a very fact but it's more
more opinion-based over here to break it
down even further real quick just to
step into the fat zone for a second
mcdonald's used to make their own orange
drink and then started pimping it out to
the ic to make it back in the day when
we were kids i didn't know that that
stuff was unbelievable it's not as good
as in the in the fountain now you know
what that makes it because it does taste
different because when i was a child it
was my go-to because we were in i was
just everybody's going
to drink and they had it at breakfast
too so you get it all you get it right
around the clock yeah it's good stuff oh
it is good stuff it's a good drink
anything with drink after it is like i
like yeah wah wah orange drink what used
to be pretty tight back in oh i never
tried that i was always wah-wah
chocolate milk yeah pretty good too
[Music]
milk shout out to one boy and their
breakfast sandwich bar none hands down
the best breakfast yeah we were just
talking about
croissant and i didn't realize that's my
brother pointed this out even like i
always go to like those little heaters
that they have on the counter but you
guys go to the counter you go to the
actual sandwich counter and they can
pull one out for you at any time
i didn't [ __ ] know that until a year
ago and i'm like i've been living my
whole life as a lie i like having the
the little little heat lamp on it yeah
yeah i like it one side's a little a
little bit harder yeah a little bit
crustier well i like it because it's
like a rest stop i love when you can
touch your own food in a rest stop and
like just take it off like everything
grab it and go yeah i like that a lot
yeah they used to have that they don't
do that too much anymore you'd be able
to grab like the personal pizza or
whatever at like a [ __ ]
rory rogers that rest stop still doing
that's the only place that you can find
a roy rogers these days
yeah yeah yeah
i don't know who he pissed off or what
happened he was killing it he [ __ ]
disappeared they whacked him yeah and
they were awesome they were [ __ ]
legit awesome way better roast beef
sandwich than arby's
wow i think it's way better 100 thick
burgers in the 80s the fixings bar yeah
yes that's where you ever go to parties
parties
is that west coast or south carolina
but it's like hardy's and something else
are linked up carl's carl's jr yeah yeah
yeah
i knew something
are you a hardy's guy
he doesn't have a mic why are you going
down you [ __ ] bozo so i can get their
reaction
um all right this one's from uncle uncle
cracker barrel
perfect that's really good
if you're paying the bill at a
restaurant with a credit card and
leaving a cash tip do you put the cash
in with the card or leave the cash after
the check comes back my mother puts the
cash in with the card
so the waiter has a chance to say thank
you oh wow
that guy needs to go to therapy that's
[ __ ] nuts i can't imagine that has
not leaked onto his own childhood that's
got to be that seems so tactical
when they give the card for her to run
it the cash is in there yeah the cash is
for you put it put the meal on the card
nothing wrong with that move i disagree
but if you're if you're just sitting
there waiting for a thank you that's the
part that i'm like that's a little weird
but why but they're gonna come back with
the card and the tip is always left they
give you the receipt you leave the tip
and then you leave i don't know i'm a
big fan of wanting to for them to know
so you'll never do that and to say
they're gonna know though who do they
think left it a ghost
you want to have that little moment of
hey thank you mal thank you so much man
let them know that you get it you know
they're doing it right i guess if you're
leaving like a really like during the
holidays if you do like a fun thing
where you like tip
on like a 50 bill or something like that
it's it's fun to like i guess like see
the joy but if it's just a regular like
standard twenty percent to you're out of
your mind you never do 20. it's always
25 30. what okay what yeah good for you
you want to get that little thing i'm
sorry i thought that was uh that that
was already established that you're
laying heavy
i'm sure the mom sounds like she's
laying heavy too i would assume you're
not laying heavy if you want to and
it's not for you old-school people like
to do that because then the cash tips
don't get counted sure yeah well not
saying my mom does that yeah don't give
him the cash and say here's your tip
here you go yeah leave it in the book
and leave like a [ __ ] gentleman or a
lady and you write cash on the receipt
yeah of course yeah that's always cool
let's make that make sure they can't
write anything in there what i don't
like you do i was going to say this for
hard feelings this is a very patreon
content heavy episode
uh we were just at dave and busters yes
yeah my favorite place
um
and what you do
is like i'll because like we pay with a
company card right so like i'll leave
whatever and then he
goes and tips on his own as well
in addition to the tipping on the
company card but not in
so like he wants to like this is for a
me type thing wow which i find i'm like
you're you're you're undercutting the
table which is like you're going hey
they stink but here you go
i've never been out with anybody that's
ever done that do you need a job
[Applause]
hey look what's going on here it sounds
like something that you could talk about
in therapy this guy's a [ __ ] rat
that's what's going on
air in our personal business
[Laughter]
i don't know what the [ __ ] this kid
drank this morning
we're gonna have a [ __ ] team meeting
after this episode on patreon.com i'm
going to hr after this yeah you're
looking at him fatty
that was two separate occasions
on this trip remember very well and it
is from the table if like that that
night it's on the table it stays i'm tip
we're tipping i think there's no one's
on the table it's just you toby you yeah
it was me him and so because he's
shaking his head you're shaking your
head obviously the two people you're
with are offended by this move you
offended by it it's from all of us
yeah you might as well say you might as
well say [ __ ] rats
let's just get into it now what are you
what what does that do for you
[Laughter]
are we gonna do the show big man are we
gonna do sports or something yeah it's
just a question foley's gonna start one
of those instagrams where he just like
films himself giving money to homeless
people look how great i am
look how awesome i am
[Laughter]
first of all [ __ ] you guys
second of all
it is from the table it's just another
nice little j listen i got what about
you moving forward i will i will put it
in the envelope but i want to know what
the motivation is
when you when you did it those two times
what was your motivation truly like what
was in your heart i
you know that is a move right when
somebody has to take a drink before they
answer a question it means they're
trying to think of something else that's
not the truth yeah that's why i did it
do i know she wanted to make sure i'm
running out of the playbook here what
are you talking about
he's got the manual what i wanted to say
is let's go backwards chronologically
the dave and buster's situation we were
in the middle of a snowstorm they they
took us late she was very very nice oh
um and i just wanted to give her
something extra for that that's all and
then i the night before okay and maggie
mcfly's shout out two of them there's a
thousand of them in northeast new york
um
there was the same situation i had
gotten there late and she was really
nice and and i just gave her 20. i agree
how it looks to put it under the glass
but you're handing it to her directly
yes i agree
but i think i think maggie mcflies i did
put it in the check or it was disgust to
put it in the check and you said no
ah yes
as a matter of fact i don't understand
you're the only person i've ever gone
out with because i'm tipping
individually okay well here's somebody
who doesn't need therapy i see what i
did i completely i'll continue to do it
i'm going to tip her more you bald [ __ ]
yeah get petty with it [ __ ] it no i will
i will i will amend that behavior in the
future the next time it happens and i
look forward to the time you believe
that i look forward i look forward to
the time where i can prove that to you
whenever that said time may be
but i just and i mean that sincerely
okay so if it's a company card that
means it's shared finances why didn't
you just say like hey it's a snowstorm i
think we should tip a little more than
we usually do and he would i tipped her
i think probably 30 35 i don't know i
got like [ __ ] nine ips to me i'm
trying to flex a little bit what the
[ __ ] it feels good to tip especially in
circumstances such as i waited tables
for a super super long time yeah over
tipping is super is really really fun
yeah it is it's funny
i'm not fighting you on the over tipping
yeah i'm just fighting you i'm putting
it under your glasses yeah i'm still a
narcissist at the end of the day fair
fair okay that's a fair response very
self-aware response i wanted to know
it's for me okay about these other three
losers
hey you know the guy who's actually
running the show this is not from him
i remember that when you're when it's
time to cut your paycheck um just
imagine you're sitting at a desk
yeah
your check comes along
complaining about every check he writes
out really funny uh this one's some of
our employees an awful lot of money
uh this one's a home run this is from
tool uh i haven't had one read yet
when you are done vacuuming do you walk
over and unplug it or just yank it out
of the wall
i'm a yankee you know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna do you one further i press the
button that retracts the chord and that
yeah
nice and let me tell you something and
then it whips me in the remember when
they hit back in the day yeah yeah
remember when the [ __ ] when the
retracting cord hit
you felt like indiana jones that was
like a bullwhip
goodbye knots goodbye tangles fantastic
always yank
everything what kind of vacuums you're
working with
right now right now we got dyson dyson
fish what about you i don't know
christina bought it for me i can't
remember what it is that was probably
dyson it was a it was a gift
i don't think it's a dicing i don't know
i don't think it was an upright though
right it was uh it's like that dyson's
an all-right machine it's a small yeah
like it's small and it has a wheel it's
not a dyson but it's nice i don't know
what it is
i tweet them like every day like you
guys should make a vibrator i have my
hair i have your hair
right off i have your hair dryer i have
your air humidifier and i have your
vacuum
would they be able to get away with that
or would they would they get in trouble
for something like that she makes a
magic wand there you go
oh you don't know people start breaking
breaking their balls about it that is a
fantastic idea because it is a really
good company man i want to see that guy
who does the dyson ads like that you
know like that that's like mr dyson i
want to see him talk about a vibrator
he's kind of high yeah
i want to see him talk about it
okay yeah i want to get one of those
hand dryers in my house that's like
that's one of my goals you know what i
do something yeah just talking about
that i'm washing my hand and it's the
one that's like just like one funnel
down the accelerator you can make fart
noises yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm a big hand dryer kind of guy
i hate the ones that are on the sink yes
yeah like a rest stop or something i
don't mean this or the ones that are
just like like they're at like rest
stops i never even saw that it just it's
like a [ __ ] tube that comes out and
you keep your hand at the sink and water
just blows it's oh it's the stupidest
thing i've ever seen since you're
confessing
to the janitor's closet
hold on unless i'm pooping in there i'm
done washing my hands at those things i
walk out and just [ __ ] use hand
sanitizer cool trash
well if it's really dirty
a new jersey they're all really dirty
they're disgusting gross yeah i sanitize
sanitize up sanitize once i'm at a porta
potty i saw like a human
piece of poop just sitting like on the
on the edge
and like i i couldn't even wear those
jeans that i wore in that porta potty
again because i was so scared by that
yeah wait experience
saw the poop before you said that or
after you sat down no no no number one
like who the [ __ ] is sitting down in a
porta potty before you went oh yeah no i
saw it but i had to like it was an
emergency like i had to
get the pee out of my body and you could
driving and like this was the only place
for miles like i had to do it i was
going to have like a medical problem
there was only one toilet there yeah and
then yeah and then also once you see the
poop you've already been traumatized so
it might as well release the pee like
true you're right
like something when i see a gruesome
scene in a toilet situation that is like
ingrained in my memory for months ago i
know i have trouble eating because i
think about it because you can watch
[ __ ] [ __ ] up videos online and it
doesn't stay with you that's not true in
isis video i couldn't eat i like almost
couldn't eat for two weeks when i saw a
guy getting breakfast oh okay okay yeah
that's pretty bad
that's [ __ ] up t-bone pull one up
oh my god i will fall out the window
holy [ __ ]
all right let's do a few more here
um this is from itchy uh
i mean our fans are bonkers
do you have any empty shampoo bottles
currently in your shower no i'm a woman
yes oh
hell no i'm me i'm getting all cluttered
i'm bad with that yeah
well spotless i'll leave like a little
bit left and then i'll be like well i'll
use it one day but then i move on to the
new shampoo and then i never end up
using it yeah i've moved corinne a
couple times and there's a lot of
bottles that are like almost she isn't
like wasting things i waste things i'm a
big waster yeah i waste
paper towels yeah i'll always paper
towels in that all toast waffles and
then put the butt and i'll wrap it in
paper towels to get that butter to melt
just like i want
[Laughter]
yeah yeah that's all right dude where
did you ever pull water if you're like
already low and you put water in there
to mix it up that's all right but if you
leave it in the airplane and use it
with cold water i was going to say i put
milk and salad dressing to get
a little bit extra yeah no that's what
you do that's there's already dairy in
the salad dressing christina what are
you talking about
ranch dressing
if you want to spice up a little ranch
yeah get a little legs out what do you
think the creaminess that a creamy
dressing is coming from powder love
powder or something yeah yeah yeah no
it's dutch i'm not putting
talked about this but if you forget that
you put water in the shampoo and then
leave it there and then [ __ ] you hit
yourself with it freezing cold it's
[ __ ] horrible it's like hairspray in
the face yeah it's not good that's true
i had a fun time
um all right this is from preston uh did
you ever wear a von dutch trucker hat no
no yeah neither they were
very two thousands yeah very britney
spears getting into paris hilton's car
well i realized our ages and i realized
you were could have been trying to be
cool at that age i was i liked them i
didn't know where to find them
i couldn't get my i tried to get my
hands on that and then hearty t-shirt
yeah i had it at a hearty t-shirt it
didn't look right on me my titties did
you have an affliction t-shirt huh that
was affliction was that the other brand
that was like at hearty i might have had
one of them yeah yeah
dutch hat was expensive though i
couldn't afford it at that time that's
what put them out oh there's a pretty
good documentary on hulu or something
yeah yeah it was a lot it's a wild story
moving i gotta get this kid
[Laughter]
uh all right this is from bkxc
uh this is this is written from a male's
perspective but we'll switch it have you
ever been on your boyfriend's shoulders
at a concert and flash the crowd no no
but i go out on my balcony every night
naked so similar what yeah i've seen
those instagram
[Laughter]
how far away is the next building now
why is that crazy
i don't i mean uh from my perspective
there's no one around the build like
it's just just right i shower in my
jeans you're crazy i think i'd be going
outside naked on a balcony that sounds
like a therapy issue yeah yeah i
performed stand up naked at the creek in
the cave yeah what yeah
i'm just saying it from parent from a
parental standpoint you don't want
people i don't want people gawking at
her that's all
i was telling her
you're welcome
but yes of course there's a lot of new
construction in my area so the only
building tall enough is there's no
residents in it yet well that's cool but
i will continue to go on the balcony
naked when there are residents what is
that just like uh it's a freedom cleaner
when what other opportunity does one
have to be outside naked i respect the
way i respect the ability to do it i'm
on the 26th floor ain't nobody's
stopping me yeah i go in my backyard
naked definitely yeah why wouldn't you
that's just more laziness if i sleep and
i let the dog out it's not like a hot
thing to experience stuff naked i
wouldn't do it in case people are eating
but
that's considerate
i said it was just summer parental
i'm not close to building you're not a
dad i'm aware of that i was it was the
spur of the moment it was that goddamn
therapist
taking heat for being nice uh
no yeah i mean that is yeah that's not
there's nothing wrong with it but that
is a shocking thing to do
i mean
so many more shocking things and i'm
like yeah
it's like a thing that people say it's
shocking that actually isn't shocking i
think is what i would categorize it okay
do you ever drive topless there was a
girl in my high school that would drive
pretty cool she needed it there pull up
in a while with that going on
all right that's like lady gaga energy
did you see that
doc where she just takes her shirt off
mid conversation it's one of my
favorites you know you can legally women
can legally walk around topless in new
york city you can actually walk around
completely naked and i remember when i
was um when i was a receptionist at core
yeah real estate company it was on the
ground level it was all glass so i could
see everything there this girl would
like walk by completely naked
wow
damn oh good for her yeah nice okay was
she hot she was hot really because it's
usually not the hot one
right the nudist colonies never have the
people you want to see
and you know you just where you don't
want somebody to grab her or something
like that
oh that's sweet that's all okay but i
think that's kind of probably you look
at me like i'm with a guy who's going to
grab her
like i don't want anybody grab it
you know what i'm saying
i think that's kind of part of the home
all day
the unbuttoned flannel doesn't help
either
i love them
i think i'm scoring points with fisher
um all right let's do one more time and
then we gotta get out of here what'd you
say
my daddy used to drive i'll take it
he was uh cremated in an uh unbuttoned
flannel hell yeah really all right
really that's awesome the flannel was
cremated as well yeah everything's
coming off yeah they don't make you they
don't get you christina balcony ready
and then put you in
wait why would they cremate you with
clothes on i assume that you have
pre-made it naked it's more like yeah
right the cadaver no you're not it's
more it's more like human oh huh you're
there you actually purchase a whole box
that gets cremated it's the whole box
that burns with the body and the whole
thing the whole way oh really i can put
my gi joes in there yeah probably yeah
well i mean we we took a lot of the
stuff out that we put with him but yeah
yeah no you it's it's a it's a special
box that is meant to be cremated and the
whole thing goes in together yeah okay
yeah all right that makes sense yeah i
like it um
sorry i know we can't talk about death
on this podcast obviously their therapy
isn't working here no i was i was
thinking guys we're all gonna climb up
real quick
i think i still would want to choose to
be nick i would want to be naked in that
the most natural when you want to be
naked because then you're giving someone
an extra job because they had to dress
you for the wake and then undress you
again yeah who's going to clean up the
people yeah they had to turn you over
i want to go naked or be planted in a
tree like people are starting to do now
they put in a little pod and you become
the tree you can become fireworks which
was my life
that was my [ __ ] boat which was
completely garbage that is garbage
that's amazing my vote was fireworks i
could still do it i have we all you know
we divvied up the ashes so i could i
could do fireworks with mine fourth of
july big man
i'd take out baltimore
[Laughter]
the sum of all fears
all right this one's from zayn uh never
had a question read anyone in your
family born outside of a hospital
he said i was born in the backyard
that's i don't think anybody would
actually we're all hospitalized yeah no
one in my family was can't think of
anyone yeah
no
i don't know what am i [ __ ] leonard
skinner
yeah i was born in a hospital that's
really funny i think bathtubs are
becoming pretty big well i was gonna say
oh yeah of course
of course of course you could do that
home birthday i thought for sure you
meant that it wasn't meant to happen
wherever it was yeah i mean no for sure
that's i mean i don't think it was back
back like a high school basketball game
or something yeah walking through a
coals
a water broke
a burlington go factory first oh man if
you're born in a burlington man
all right gang
guys thank you so much for coming and
sitting with us thank you so much the
special's out right now yes we love you
today yes thank you guys you're amazing
what do you want the folks out there to
know
our special day youtube.com guys we
[ __ ] without the you and [ __ ] check
out guys we [ __ ] on the luminary app
uh or wherever you get uh podcasts uh
yeah it's wide release now so you don't
have to pay complete garbage check it
out social media guys we [ __ ] without
the you and [ __ ] i'm at christina
hutch and i'm at philanthropy gal
you guys are the best we love you today
thank you so much what do you got for
him uh cameron comedy on all social
media check out our tour we're on the
road all over the place and
patreon.com check it out yeah we'll see
you next week peace